[Music]
on this Tuesday night gaza's second
largest city surrounded Israel's
intensifying ground
offensive as life keeps getting worse
for Palestinians who have nowhere to
flee sexual misconduct in Canada's
military On The Rise victims are showing
that they do not trust this institution
the troubling new findings and what
Advocates say needs to change now
politics and helping the house the
disproportionate way federal funds are
allocated for affordable housing let it
go after being frozen to the seaf floor
a 1 trillion ton iceberg is now on the
move and she's a soccer game changer I
don't know what it's going to look like
without her Christine Sinclair's
teammates on her immeasurable influence
beyond the
pitch global national with Donna freie
good evening and thanks for joining us
Israel's Army appears to be moving into
another new and deadly phase in its war
on Hamas it is pushing deeper into
Southern Gaza making life increasingly
perilous for people who have nowhere to
go gaza's Health Ministry run by Hamas
says nearly 16,000 people have been
killed including 6,000 children
hospitals are severely overcrowded there
aren't enough staff or medical supplies
the UN says 80% of gaza's population
about 1.8 million people have now been
displaced there's nowhere for them to go
many are intense with nowhere to even
wash their hands Israel imposed a
Communications blackout across Gaza
yesterday knocking out the internet
that's now being restored and there are
reports water pumps have been set up to
flood tunnels in Gaza with seawater to
try to drive Hamas Fighters above ground
Danielle Hamin has our top story tonight
in a warning some of the images are
distressing
gaza's second biggest city is now a
battlefield the Israel Defense Forces
say they're now encircling
canun by now after 8 weeks of
bombardment these scenes might seem
repetitive to some watching from the
outside but they're no less traumatizing
for those trapped and unable to
escape
they launched mortars at us at night
says this boy we were scared and did not
sleep 6-year-old Lana Abus Safi told the
man who carried her in that she was
hungry and thirsty M and that she wanted
her mother the UN recently called Gaza a
graveyard for children but then there
are those whose parents are the ones who
were killed what chocked me the most
were the children with a atrocious
injuries and at the same time having
lost their parents with no one looking
after them the residents of Kan Yunis
which include those who fled from the
north last month have been told to leave
Israel is dropping leaflets and telling
them to go to safer ground but according
to Residents no such place now exists
here this woman is appalled by the
inaction of the Arab
world the Arab leaders she says they're
just watching and doing nothing what
Israel considers safer ground many Gins
will tell you has no water no shelter no
toilets there are no bathrooms we cannot
even wash there is no place to bake or
get bread no Market to buy food she says
it is a completely remote area and life
in Gaza is likely about to get even
worse prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu
met today with hostages who've just been
released they told him how Hamas dressed
them in hijabs and headscarves so that
Israel wouldn't detect them that air
strikes are happening very close to
where the captives are being held one
reportedly telling Netanyahu you claimed
to have intelligence but the fact is we
were
bombed Donna Danielle Hangin in
Jerusalem thanks sexual misconduct in
the Canadian military is not new it's
been a problem for decades and now stats
Canada reports it's getting worse or at
least more people are reporting it a
stats can survey last year found nearly
2,000 regular Force members or 3.5% said
they were sexually assaulted that's more
than double the rate from the last
survey done in 2018 Global News has
broken a number of stories about sexual
misconduct in the military including in
the senior ranks lots of promises have
been made about reforms promises that as
Abigail Bean reports have not led to
much change were you expecting this to
be lower and and is it a failure that
they've climbed that they've
doubled so we are expecting to do a lot
more work in this space leftenant
General Jenny kol was tasked with
changing the culture in the Canadian
Armed Forces two years ago a period that
saw the ousting of a number of senior
members over sexual misconduct scandals
a former Supreme Court Justice calling
the military a broken system that's a
liability to the country in a wide-
ranging report and countless government
promises for
reform now more than twice as many
regular Force members say they were
sexually assaulted than when the last
survey was done in 2018 a lot more
analysis needs to go into that before we
actually uh uh determine what what this
raise means an increase in reporting is
deeply concerning to us but I think it
can also be indicative of of a a perhaps
greater confidence among victims that if
they do come forward and and
bring forward their complaints that they
will be taken seriously we have clear
evidence that victims are not coming
forward because they don't trust the
institutions so this is a failure on all
accounts according to the report most
people did not report incidents the
biggest reason why they didn't think it
would make a difference or they feared
consequences and in fact two-thirds of
those who did report said they faced
negative consequences anything from
bullying to retaliation and reprisal so
so this is clearly a barrier a lot of
emphasis done on the um complaint
management system uh which we are
completely re uh overhauling it is going
to take time and numbers like today are
disappointing but they should not take
us off our course I think the message
that this is a complex problem that is
going to take a long time to fix is a
rhetorical tool to avoid accountability
Advocates say change in the Canadian
Armed for forces has taken long enough
and for a government that has said its
top priority in the military is to fix
this problem there seem to be no
explanations Tuesday as to why the
problem persists other than saying it
will take more time abigil Bean Global
News Ottawa the federal government is
investing $71 million in nonprofit
housing co-ops which are owned and
operated by the people who live in them
as a result of a sustained lack of
investment for decades uh Canada now is
facing a shortage of affordable housing
in the ecosystem that manifests itself
in a lot of very challenging ways now we
can change that but not without
sustained direct investment by the
federal government in affordable housing
the government is planning to build
nearly 1,200 new co-ops the rest of the
money will be used to retrofit existing
structures in Quebec BC Ontario and New
Brunswick the need for housing in one
small New Brunswick town is so acute it
has declared a local state of emergency
not long ago someone died in a Park in
St Steven New Brunswick and as Heidi
petruk explains the Declaration calls
out the province for failing to address
the
crisis with winter weather already here
Canadians living outside are at risk and
now in New Brunswick town has taken
Extraordinary Measures after tragedy
Municipal District of St Steven
Emergency Services were forced to
respond to a fatal fatality of a
resident in a public space that death
over the weekend prompted Council for St
Steven a community of of 8100 to declare
a local state of emergency blaming the
province for inaction and lack of
funding to tackle homelessness a
municipality doesn't have a toolbox to
do this you know I I don't have a budget
for this this that's not our mandate you
know I we I can't go in and take care of
Social Services Social Development and
Welfare the New Brunswick government has
fired back stating it intends to
terminate the town's declaration saying
it's only for quote true emergencies
society as a whole often sees
homelessness as an urban issue yet St
Steven is not alone inflation High rents
lack of public housing and low basic
incomes she says all adding up into
crisis I've been to communities with a
thousand people or less in who are also
finding they have and didn't have before
are are having uh issues with
homelessness and other incidents have
punctuated the
urgency just last week A New Brunswick
nonprofit released a shocking video
showing a man sleeping in a dump emptied
into a garbage truck fortunately he was
rescued and police in Halifax found a
man dead at this encampment as well many
agencies and shelters are at their
limits and so everyday people are now
stepping in on the ground where they say
governments have
not two citizens helped bring in these
special winter tents calling for all
levels of government to come together if
this is not resolved people are going to
die and it's as simple as that we did
not take this lightly with st Steven
left in an apparent stalemate with the
province and more than 100 unhoused the
mayor worries what will happen once
winter officially arrives Heidi pic
Global News
Halifax many municipalities are looking
to the federal government to fund
temporary shelters and affordable
housing David aen has been analyzing how
money from one multi-billion dollar
Federal fund has been allocated over the
last few years and he found it is
disproportionally gone to large Urban
centers David well Donna the federal
government has several programs to help
build affordable homes one was called
the rapid Housing Initiative or
rhi it was a $4 billion program launched
during the pandemic in 2020 designed
largely to get people out of crowded
shelters where they might more easily
catch covid and into their own
affordable housing units federal funds
were used to build thousands of new
units over the last 3 years by
converting Hotel or motels or quickly
building modular housing units I think
the rhi is one of the best programs in
the National Housing strategy a global
news analysis though shows that rhi
funds by and large went to projects in
large Urban centers with fewer projects
funded in the country's smaller cities
that Trend also had a political bias
because conservative MPS are under
represented in Canada's large Urban
cores while new Democrats are over
represented consider this about 8% of
the country is represented by a new
democrat MP but nearly 19% of rhi funds
went to NDP writings meanwhile 34% of
the country has a conservative MP but
those writings got just 15% of the funds
as for Liberal writings 48% of Canadians
live in those writings and 49% of the
funding went to those writings the
federal housing Minister says that
partisan skew was not intentional that
there's not decisions taken to
deliberately fund one opposition party
more it's a function of the projects
that come into the fund for application
that meet scoring criteria but that
scoring criteria the program design
introduced its own biased more rhi money
for big cities and proportionately less
for smaller ones homelessness exists in
these uh rural communities but it's not
measured and so that presents a
challenge the geography of homelessness
has changed in the past several years
when it comes to Rapid Housing
Initiative there was by design an urban
bias and what governments cannot count
or have trouble counting governments
cannot fund and so that the experts say
is one of the first things that needs to
be done to meet this growing
homelessness problem in the country's
smaller municipalities count the
homeless and quantify the problem in
order to qualify for federal funding
Donna okay d David aen in Ottawa thank
you the world's largest iceberg is on
the Move coming up the problems this
massive chunk of ice could
[Music]
cause Rescuers in Indonesia have
recovered 11 more bodies after Sunday's
volcanic eruption on Mount Mori 22
people were killed one person is still
missing and 12 others are being treated
in hospital more than 50 climbers were
rescued after that initial eruption and
new eruptions have since hampered rescue
and Recovery efforts a record number of
lobbyists who work with the fossil fuel
industry are at the climate conference
in Dubai an analysis by environmental
groups found more than 2400 lobbyists
with ties to the fossil fuel industry
are registered for cop 28 that's more
than almost every country delegation
this year and nearly four times the
number of lobbyists who registered last
year the jump could partly be due to a
new requirement that attend declare who
they represent a rule introduced by the
UN after years of pressure for greater
transparency the biggest iceburg in the
world is on the move for the first time
in more than three decades a23a as it's
known is a massive sheet of ice that has
garnered Global attention as it quickly
drifted Beyond Antarctica and into the
open ocean Eric Sorenson explains how it
got there and what it could
mean it stretches across the horizon as
far as the eye can see Iceberg
a23a one Antarctic scientist said it
feels like sailing alongside a new
country only it's a country of solid ice
and now it's on the move slowly over
time it would melt a bit off and then
what happened about a year ago or so is
that it became buoyant enough that
actually started to float it was at one
time a glacier sliding at top Antarctica
until a massive piece broke off the ice
shelf in 1986 4,000 square km the
largest iceberg in the world it is more
than 2third the size of Prince Edward
Island one Iceberg it was grounded for
about 35 years but this year began
moving through the wendle sea just since
October satellite images show it
drifting quickly Beyond Antarctica into
the southern Atlantic Ocean next stop
could be the south Georgia islands and
keep in mind that colossal thing we can
see is only the tip of the
iceberg up to 90% % of icebergs are
below the surface the biggest ones could
threaten Communications cables in
Shallow areas and overall could pose a
risk to Ocean vessels in shipping lanes
it could still um make its way
reasonably far north up towards kind of
South Africa um where it can disrupt
shipping Antarctica always has lots of
icebergs thousands if you count the
small ones but more are being created
and they're melting faster we have
warmed the climate of Antarctica and now
it's answering back raising in sea
levels and affecting ocean currents it's
important to track icebergs in real time
as they melt they deliver the fresh
water into the ocean that's a fresh
water flux into the ocean then can
impact the ocean circulation it all
points to global warming that is putting
Antarctica's ice shelves under stress
they uh could potentially melt more
quickly and that will lead to more of
these icebergs but also lead to sea
level rise it's really uh another sign
that will really change the the climate
and uh you know we don't have much time
to to reverse these things before the
impacts become catastrophic a23a will
probably melt in the next four years but
more big icebergs are coming Eric senson
Global News
Toronto it's so warm and Calgary today
some people hit the
links the city opened two Gulf courses
as temperatures reached 15° but the
shinook winds also fueled this large
grass fire near the city of ay some
residents were briefly forced to flee
but emergency crews say that fire is now
under control the harm of social
isolation ahead how loneliness can
affect your
[Music]
health this Christmas ad for Charlie's
Bar in Northern Ireland is really struck
a cord with people it's been viewed more
than 10 million times now it shows an
elderly man on his own stopping by the
pub for a p and thanks to a friendly dog
he strikes up a conversation with some
young people the ad shows how kindness
and a simple hello can make such a
difference to those who are alone and
that applies everywhere new data from
Canada's National Institute on Aging
suggests social isolation and loneliness
is a growing problem 41% of older
Canadians reported being socially
isolated 58% say they experienced
loneliness in the past year doctors say
loneliness can have an impact on your
health
this can lead to more mental health
concerns this can lead to more physical
stress social isolation and loneliness
is as bad for your health as smoking 15
cigarettes a day it's also linked to
Serious conditions such as dementia and
cardiovascular disease the report calls
for a national strategy on programs that
help seniors connect to social
activities and of course kindness and
friendliness from all of us can go a
long way
too Christine Sinclair's swan song next
her teammates reflect on her remarkable
career Rocking around the Christmas tree
at the Christmas party H it's taken 65
years for that song to reach number one
Brenda Lee recorded it in 1968 when she
was just 13 and now it's reach number
one on the Billboard Hot 100 thanks to
streaming services and that makes Lee
now 78 the oldest person to ever top the
Billboard Chart well it feels like
Christine Sinkler has been playing
soccer for Canada forever but the woman
who is at the top of her game is about
to bow out she'll play her last game
with Team Canada tonight in front of a
HomeTown crowd in Vancouver in a stadium
that for tonight has been renamed in her
honor quite the Accolade for a player
who loves the game but not the Limelight
NE Gara on the mark Christine Sinclair
leaves on soccer
the world's leading all-time scorer's
final practice before her last game has
teammates reflecting on how she's
impacted them my whole journey with the
national team has involved her and I
don't know what it's going to look like
without her little moments that she
probably has no idea about have changed
a lot of Our Lives votes of confidence
she says constantly coming from Sinclair
changed the game for younger teammates
they say Sinclair herself is unassuming
humble and doesn't try to grab the
spotlight as much as she's changed the
world in soccer and changed the
country's landscape of soccer she still
wants more for us than she's ever wanted
for herself for the day BC place has
been renamed as Christine Sinclair place
at Sunday's practice Sinclair said now
that she's back in the region where
she's making her International farewell
the moment is finally starting to hit
her I think it's kind of sinking in now
that this is it just trying to enjoy
every every moment um and it's it's
actually really enjoyable to play soccer
without any stress and yeah it's got a
it's a nice
feeling the Olympic gold medalist
doesn't look stressed on the field
though she makes it look easy teammates
say and has fun we have to remember all
the countless hours that sink has been
working on and off the pitch right that
people don't see she's got a sense of
humor that's hilarious she keeps us
laughing holding an endorsement from her
Canadian coach Sinclair has hinted she
wants to get into coaching SLE make an
unbelievable coach Sinclair has has said
she plans to continue playing
professionally with Portland this season
she's also talked of extended vacations
and spending time with family for now
her
331st International game brings to an
end a chapter she started at age 16 Nea
Global News
Vancouver and that is global national
for this Tuesday I'm Donna Freez and her
star has sha so bright for so long it is
hard to imagine Canadian Soccer without
Christine Sinclair she made her debut
with the Canadian national team as nud
said at age 16 and she's never looked
back we leave you tonight with some
snapshots from her legendary career
Canada's greatest of all time thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow
[Music]
bye-bye